la pratique du fat bike c'est un vélo à
plus d'un sur dimensionné pour rouler
dans la neige est un nouveau sport
d'hiver de plus en plus populaire
d'ailleurs et pour en parler je joue un
gilles morneau qui est chroniqueur au
magazine vélo mag et auteur du guide du
fat bike
bonjour monsieur bordeaux - jour là je
dois dire que je l' ai déjà fait je
l'utilisé sur la plage j'ai adoré mais
je ne savais pas qu'on pouvait faire du
fun bike sur la neige est là ce qu'on
dit c'est que sa grande popularité
ouais effectivement nos voisins du sud
en font plus sur la plage ici au québec
on a quelque chose d'une ressource et la
neige alors on développe est vraiment
une expertise pour des amis des sentiers
sur la neige spécialement c'est
intéressant alors là vous allez nous
expliquer un peu c'est quoi ça vient
d'où premièrement et où ça commence et
finalement d'un commencé avec une course
de chiens dans en alaska qui s'appelle
la haye des terroirs bon et qui est une
grande course de chiens de 300 km et des
dégâts qui sont mis dans la tête de la
file en vélo alors ils sont patentes et
des vélos qui pouvait porter sur la
neige sur sur les sentiers de motoneige
labo sur les lacs gelés
alors il le ion développé des roues plus
larges pour prendre acte et les pourra
commander leurs roues plus larges pour
développer des codes plus large plus
toutes sortes de composants ta fonction
de ça puis vers 2005 est le premier
modèle de production qui a été lancée
puis depuis ce temps là ça fait boule de
neige
tous les manufacturière nov maintenant
et c'est rendu un produit très abouti
ouais c'est vrai ça mais c'est ce que je
remarque c'est que ça vient du nord
finalement donc au départ c'était pour
la neige là effectivement mieux aussi
avancé il ya eu des des balbutiements
qu'andy goode et qui a décidé de faire
3000 km à travers le sahara
bon c'est pas tenter un buste un
ingénieur alors il sait pas quand mais
un vélo à deux roues motrices théâtre où
mes deux roues motrices avec des roues
très large nous fait bike actuelle donc
ça serait ça serait un peu lourd à
porter maintenant mais lui a traversé
sahara avec ça donc ça marche bien sur
le sens à ce qu'il y ait sur la neige
également rappelé nous la différence en
vélo toile on le voit d'ailleurs on a
des images le vélo de montagne et le
feedback c'est la roule c'est vraiment
la large
du pneu un fat bike va avoir un pneu de
4 pouces ou 5 pouces de large sur
l'argent qui fait 100 mm de large au
lieu de 20 mm de large comme sur un vélo
de montagne normal c'est un petit peu
comme un vélo de montagne mais en grèce
est vraiment là pour pouvoir porter sur
la neige sont toutes les
conditionnements j'entends déjà des
questions déjà la maison alors est-ce
que c'est abordable combien ça coûte
pour s'équiper
la plupart des fêtes bike qui qui qui se
vendent sur le marché ils coûtent entre
1000 et 2000 dollars ok en bout en bout
de mille dollars c'est un petit peu ardu
à acheter sur le ca c'est moins fiables
mais entre 1000 et 2000 puis souvent sur
ce sur le marché d'usagers ont pu la
voir en boîte de 1000 de rome
évidemment ça peut aller dans les cinq
dix mille comme tous les vélos
car katia des passionnés qui décide
d'avoir le vélo le plus léger et le plus
performant mais en groupe pour 2015 100
dollars à voir vous avez raison il ya
plusieurs mais nous savons également
donc milles jusqu'à 1500 $ le programme
avait très dispendieux vous êtes un
grand amateur de fat bike pour ceux qui
n'ont jamais expérimenté la chose
qu'elle conseille aux preneurs donné
c'est d'aller sur le site de vélo-québec
velo.qc.ca de regarder le répertoire des
sentiers de vélo de montagne de cocher
l'onglet fat mike le ils vont apparaître
90 ou 4,97 destinations à travers le
québec où ces permis et tout s'est
organisé pour faire du fatah et en
combien de kilomètres est un peu partout
au québec de sentiers pour faire du
falga de kilomètres je ne sais pas par
destination ça va être entre 10 et 40 km
ok commun mais ce qui est bon dans ces
destinations le sait que plusieurs
offres la location trackback alors c'est
pas nécessaire de s'équiper avant de
savoir si on va aimer ça alors on attend
une belle journée on attend que ça fasse
quelques jours qui occupe pas nager pour
être sûrs que les pistes sont bien
compact et et là on se réserve cette
banque en ligne
on s'envoie d'ensemble de location on
essaye cependant quelques rares et
souvent on attrape les piqûres et on
s'achète un fadeaway construite et plus
un billet de saison
est ce qu'on peut et est-ce qu'on peut
même faire du fat boys band et des
sentiers de raquette dans des sens
c'est également de ce qu'il faut ou
sapera spécifiquement des sentiers qui
sont eux qui sont faits pour le fun bike
c'est plus le fun quand c'est des
sentiers vraiment d'amis pour le fath
bike avec des motoneiges
par contre moi j'ai un chalet au nord de
québec et j'utilise presque
exclusivement des sentiers de motoneige
mais pas des sentiers de motoneige
fédéric qui roulait il ya beaucoup trop
de circulation le petit sentier de
motoneige qui donne accès aux érablière
ou au chalet au tour soyez moyen
d'explorer si on habite dans des régions
qui sont acquis sont propices à des
sentiers de ski de fond évidemment nos
roues de fatboy xv au brésil il est le
damage pour mieux s'en tenir avec des
sentiers spécifique mais il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où cela la raquette et le fat
mike sont partagés parce que c'est si le
même genre de deux configurations de
sentiers alors la plupart du temps si
c'est beau pour la raquette c'est les
raquettes d'étape est exactement le plat
pays sont acte très bien la neige alors
c'est bien le forfait des sentiers de
raquette
sauf si c'est trop sinueux ou trop pentu
évidemment il faut pour choisir ses
sentiers quand même et vous avez
également écrit un livre sur le le fait
de break alors on évite les gens aussi à
le lire pour avoir la piqûre finalement
merci beaucoup monsieur mono et vous
voyez aussi donc toutes les informations
à propos d'elly merci d'avoir été avec
un doublé et bye bye